[Music]
on the PS4 or in the game pad each each
element is mapped to a face button so
you have fire down here an X you have uh
death magic up here triangle and then
you can just mix into if you want to get
over to the other tile and get access to
the other elements oh look at that
oh
fire exploded me sorry
I'll bring you right back there you go
so if you want to get over to the other
few elements exped me again well to be
fair he he threw a grenade at you and
you blew fire on it so you can also
douse the grenade with water oh uh or
put him out completely with frost this
guy's carrying a sack of bombs here so
I'm just going to expire and death and
do that that's the beauty of magic you
can just make your own spell there you
go but if you're want to get over to the
other set of elements you just press and
hold L1 you get healing
or water and frost all that oh
sorry so new in Magic two is actually
how the Magics work you have the bar of
abilities up here of
magics and just compared to Magic one is
make it a lot faster and easier to get
access to to the Magics okay it's not I
mean it's not we're not dumping it down
by anyways you just have this way whoa
I'm not good at this hey dying is an
integral part of the wizard H this way
this way people actually use the the
Magics and the fastpaced thing I mean
you want to just instantly be able to
fill the screen with fire if that's your
thing and this way you can you just we
don't we don't have that magic here but
you can just instantly fill the
responsibly fill the screen with fire if
that's your thing or uh for this matter
here the Thunderbolt sorry about that
you should probably not walk in there
there's some angry clouds above what is
this fairy doing uh this fairy it's a
familiar and they will just follow you
around and if when the last player dies
uh it will sacrifice itself and bring
you back so it will resurrect you if
you're dead basically it's kind of like
a floating extra
life hey check this out uh a little
homage to another game we like oh you
can actually you can actually pick up
that fungus and use it for I want the
mushroom I got the mushroom infinite
mushrooms that's another picture in this
game oh well that was short lived got to
bring you back
shortlived
mushroom I want
it way oh sorry for the push
there I'm hitting these things with the
Flaming mushroom oh yeah you can
actually you can by pressing if you
charge up magic and then press R2 you
can imbue your your mushroom uh with
magic yeah so now you now you have a
proper flaming mushroom you're probably
first wizard in fantasy history to be
able to say that I have a
FL I'll put up a frost bear here to keep
these guys b y there are more n can you
fall off the edge you can definitely
fall off the edge see we we don't
believe in in oh ah I'm dead here I have
some restriction ready oh we we don't
believe in controlling the player like
oh that's me I'm going it's all you now
no don't I think there's only one guy
left oh there's two guys left or there's
two guys left or I will also die there
we see the fairy doing doing her magic
check this out you can actually just
push him off water doesn't do any any
damage but you can push people away with
it oh ah there we go oh there's still
this is still pre-alpha so physics is
still a bit wonky uh we have some other
Magics here but no we don't we don't
believe in controlling players if you
want to walk up an edge you can if you
just want to fill I mean if you want to
do magic if you want to cast a rock onto
your own head go
ahead might not be a good choice but
it's your choice you
[Music]
know
Scot
[Music]
hey
a